i know that the results have been coming
in uh since this morning and
clearly and a lot more to go and it's
early days but a very encouraging set of
results so far and i think that's really
because
uh we've been focusing as as government
on
uh our priorities people's priorities
bouncing back from the uh the pandemic
as far as we can
getting through it and it's been very
good to be here at uh
seven trent uh talking to them about
uh the 500 kickstarters they're
employing uh which is i think what
everybody wants to
to see as we as we go through towards
the end of the
the road map really making sure that
we're getting people
uh into work getting the economy
bouncing back very
very strongly uh in the in the way that
i know it will anyway i'll i'll i'll be
saying a bit more later on
in in hartley pool take care rory you
want questions
yes of course offering the alternative
to astrazeneca to the under 40s
well that's a matter for the for the
jcvi and uh
i think what they're saying is that uh
you know if if
uh if you've got a choice
and uh you've got uh you know you've got
a variety of jabs
and and you've got somebody under 40
then on the whole uh give them
uh give them fizer or one of the other
ones so that that so it's a
it's a it's a preference not a not a an
absolute ruling and what are your
concerns on the
indian variant yes i think i think we've
got to be
uh we've got to be very careful about
that and
um we're doing a a huge amount
obviously to make sure that where we do
find
uh outbreaks of the the indian variant
that we do surge testing that we
uh do door-to-door uh testing and and
isolate it
uh and and that is and also have very
very tough controls on
uh on on uh on transport on uh people
coming in